premier rang des jeunes chercheurs venus
du monde entier andré brack
c'est lui qui a fondé dans les années 90
au sein du cnrs à orléans la première
équipe de recherche européenne sur
l'astrobiologie aux questions qu'ils se
posaient déjà l'origine de la vie
terrestre la possibilité d'émergence de
la vie ailleurs dans l'univers
une mission spatiale russe européenne va
tenter d'apporter des réponses
la mission exomars 2020 avec ce robot
destiné à explorer le sous sol de la
planète rouge le savons que large dans
sa jeunesse avait de l'eau donc avec de
l'eau qui est une des conditions pour
que la vie puisse apparaître donc avec
des océans
nous pensons que la vie avait des
chances d'apparaître toute la
problématique consiste à rechercher les
traces de vie passée sur la surface à la
surface de mars où dans son sol dans son
proche tout seul si on trouve la vie sur
mars si elle est vraiment très semblable
à la vie terrestre ce qu'on trouve aux
microbes terrestre on pourra donc dire
qu'avec probabilité qu'on descend tous
de mars
serions nous en fait des martiens de
souche pour répondre à cette question
le laboratoire d'orléans apporte une
pièce fondamentale à l'émission une
caméra microscope pour filmer les
échantillons de sous-sol avant qu'ils ne
soient broyés pour être analysé le
problème des carottes qui vont être
prélevés à deux mètres de profondeur
c'est une fois qu'on leur montre elles
vont être distribués ici dans un petit
tiroir d'accord et seul notre instrument
va pouvoir faire une image haute
résolution de la carotte puisqu'ensuite
les broyer pour faire les analyses
donc il ya toute une partie de la
formation qui est perdue lors de cette
phase de noyage donc les images qui
seront réalisés avec cet instrument sont
vraiment crucial pour faire
l'interprétation géologique des
échantillons et c'est depuis la terre la
terre orléanaise pour ce qui le concerne
que frédéric foucher et ses collègues
physiciens chimistes biologistes
analyseront les données qui leur
parviendront du petit véhicule martien
il faudra en effet attendre 2025 pour
qu'une autre mission
américano-européenne cette fois soit en
capacité de ramener sur terre
des morceaux de ce qui fut peut-être
l'origine du monde de notre monde en
tout cas